ces terres et bloque je reconnais pas
montréal
la montée de la violence armée à
montréal choc parce que des jeunes comme
here i am bendaoui jannah et d'hapoël
thomas trudel ou annie wadi en ont payé
le prix fort
pour renverser la vapeur l'anonyme un
organisme de services sociaux a embauché
deux paires et dans d'anciens criminels
repentis pour aider les jeunes coincés
dans l'engrenage des gangs de rue à s'en
sortir grâce au projet baptisé acte peut
arriver avec quelque chose qui est très
fort pour notre structure et notre
organisation et ya prime dans notre dans
notre milieu mais on apprend beaucoup
d'eux si le père est dans ce livre des
formations et des stages auprès
notamment d'organismes communautaires et
des cols avant d'être déployés sur le
terrain prêts à intervenir auprès de
jeunes qui ont parfois une carapace dure
à percer
radio canada a choisi de ne pas dévoiler
l'identité des pairs aidants afin de ne
pas nuire aux liens de confiance qu'ils
établissent avec les jeunes père absent
besoin d'appartenance à un groupe
délinquance allers retours entre la
maison et le centre jeunesse les pairs
aidants qui ont rejoint les gangs de rue
avant l'âge de 15 ans ne l'ont pas eu
facile j'ai fait quand même
rétrospection son peut dire ça comme ça
alors que je faisais un séjour au pays
dansiez je voyais ma vie défiler je me
faisais plein questionnement ce que je
passe toute ma vie en les barreaux à
courir à fuir à regarder derrière moi
tout le temps et ça m'a poussé à
tranquillement pas d'un seul coup mais
ça va pousser tranquillement à vouloir
prendre un autre chemin leur but
aujourd'hui c'est que d'autres je n'en
prennent pas le même chemin que par le
passé je m'engouffre alors plus longue
divine en dix ans le sud j'ai vu
moi-même ce jeu là c'est tout c'est
toute sa vie ce qu'il faisait en sorte
que la monétique dit ok mais tu as tu
seras avec moi une collaboration qui
selon cet expert en gangs de rue
permettra d'avoir une approche unique
auprès de jeunes fermé aux interventions
traditionnel de gens vont peut-être
avoir une plus grande ouverture pour
aborder certains sujets puisqu'il va
comprendre que raquel lui avec un peu la
même chose c'est de quoi je parle donc
ça donne une grande confiance mutuelle
en ouverture aussi le gouvernement
legault a récemment annoncé un
investissement de 52 millions de dollars
en prévention de la criminalité dont
près de la moitié est dédiée à montréal
où le problème est plus criant une bonne
nouvelle pour des projets comme actes et
ses pairs aidants qui espère bien
bénéficier de cette aide financière ici
daniel kadjo radio canada montréal